welcome to the daily climate show coming
up
eu countries warn of moving back to
coal-fired power plants to tackle
russian energy crisis
[Music]
the u.n moves a major biodiversity
summit from china to canada
and heavy rainfall in china and other
parts of asia forces thousands of people
out of their homes
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we report on the impact of
climate change hear from those most
affected and track the changes that are
responsible for those impacts on the
planet well first last year's government
around the world committed to help
tackle climate change and a big part of
that was phasing out the use of dirty
fossil fuels as an energy source but the
war in ukraine has exposed a reliance on
russian gas and as that supply gets ever
more restricted it's caused an energy
crisis and soaring prices for households
now some countries in the european union
a warning that they'll need to move to
emergency measures and shift their
reliance back to coal so let's take a
look shall we at what's being suggested
so austria's government has agreed to
convert a gas-fired power plant to use
coal in the face of an energy emergency
germany announced on sunday its latest
plant-based gas storage levels and said
it could restart coal-fired power plants
that it had aimed to phase out now the
dutch government has announced that
coal-fired energy plants in the
netherlands will be allowed to increase
their production as part of efforts to
reduce reliance on russian gas and italy
says it may declare a heightened state
of alert on gas this coming week if
russia continues to curb its supplies
which could ramp up the production at
coal-fired plants well i'm joined now by
our correspondent charlotte lomas so
what we're hearing here charlotte is
there is a reluctance to to leaning on
coal in the eu for the short term at
least there is a reluctance but this is
the reality this is the challenge that
is facing european ministers with russia
really squeezing its grip on european
gas supplies many ministers across
europe have now said that they have no
choice but to reconsider coal power
plants as an alternative energy supply
just when
many countries were hoping to to phase
that out and as you mentioned uh coal is
uh one of the greenhouse gases that just
produce uh the most uh pollution it's
known as a dirty energy source so it
will be a reluctant decision one
minister's um said has been a painful
decision um but that is the challenge
that they're facing it could be a stop
gap as you mentioned the big question is
whether this will delay that transition
away from the use of fossil fuels okay
charlotte thank you very much for that
well let's take a look at the day's
other climate news and to china now
where hundreds of thousands of people
have been forced to leave their homes as
the south of the country experiences its
heaviest rainfall since
1961 in shaogon city the flood alerts
was raised to its highest level as
authorities asked residents living along
the riverbanks to move to higher ground
while the summer rainy season happens
every year in china climate change can
bring heavier and more frequent
downpours
well all of this comes as bangladesh and
north eastern india continue to deal
with extreme flooding authorities say
they're struggling to reach
more than nine and a half million people
who have been stranded with little food
and water and the unusually heavy
monsoon rains have killed dozens of
people over the past two weeks
and more than a hundred temperature
records could be broken in the united
states this week as a heatwave continues
and most of the population will see
temperatures over 30 degrees celsius
with the southern and eastern regions
seeing the hottest temperatures
meanwhile firefighters in new jersey
have continued to battle a forest fire
which has consumed over 7 000 acres now
it's all down to dry and windy
conditions meaning the initially small
fire began to spread very quickly
now the average price for petrol and
diesel has risen to a new high according
to the rac the average price of unleaded
is now
188.74 pence per litre and while the
price of diesel is at
196.36 pence per liter an rac spokesman
said that while the price of diesel is
likely to keep rising they expect
retailers to start reducing the price of
petrol in response to a fall in
wholesale costs
now chances are you would have heard of
the cop summits that happened and
focusing on climate like the one held in
glasgow last november well the united
nations
also holds another cop meaning
conference of parties on biodiversity
and this year it's just been announced
that the summits will be moved from
china to canada because of the chinese
zero coved policy well here too tell me
a little bit more about the summit
itself um and that last minute change of
location is mark goff he's the ceo of
the capitals coalition which has been
involved in uh meetings leading up to
cop 15. thanks for joining us
mark so this delay of two years the team
will have so much to get through but how
much of that will you be able to achieve
now
well i think it's really important that
we do move this to canada and that's
been key because we've already lost two
years of this 10-year plan that we were
trying to set out so it's really
important we start moving towards
getting to some solutions
the climate cop is obviously extremely
important but biodiversity we've already
lost 83 of our wild animals 50 of plants
there's another million species that are
under threat so this is the basis of all
of the dependency that we have in life
and it's really essential that we get
this bit right
and what big aim do you want to achieve
i've been reading around this story and
there are a few people that say you know
that two-year delay lost momentum in in
really making a change
um it's lost momentum on getting to the
final decision but it's allowed a lot
more countries to actually start having
discussions around what is important and
we're talking about something here which
is very
difficult to get your head around it's
about a local issue it affects people
locally unlike climate which is a big
issue that one ton of carbon is the same
all around the world what we're talking
about here is something which is local
to people what we're really aiming for
is a global goal agreement across all of
the countries for a nature positive but
also equitable and climate neutral
approach and by nature positive we mean
there's more nature by 2030 than there
is now indeed what would be your message
mark to world leaders because i suppose
the success of um cop 26 was that big
world leaders turned up and were
involved and this will be after cop 27
in egypt it also clashes with the world
cup what would you say to leaders whose
attention might be elsewhere at this
time
well one thing um world cups are going
to happen again this is only a once in a
decade at least discussion so maybe give
up the world cup tickets to come to this
one
we do need to get the world leaders
there we do need to get the commitments
but we have started seeing this the
connection between the climate cop where
92 percent of the nationally determined
contributions the country set included
nature so these things aren't separate
they're all interconnected so we have to
get this one right world leaders have to
be there this one to get the overarching
agreement around the world
and very briefly mark what are your
thoughts on that move then we said it at
the beginning from china to canada
well like i say i mean i'm really
pleased that the uh chinese government
has agreed to move it to canada so we
can get on and do this um covert has
been such a disruption to so many people
around the world in so many ways not
just because of this biodiversity
conference but we do need to move on
with it and the fact that actually we're
finding solutions that the chinese
government is finding a solution here
that canada is picking up that the other
countries are coming together and
organizations like business for nature
which are bringing those businesses to
that conversation are going to be
essential 90 of those businesses want
that mandatory requirement for reporting
on this to change those subsidies that
are in there the 1.8 trillion dollars of
subsidies that are going in the wrong
direction so all of those efforts that
are being made have to come together and
now we've got a venue now we've got a
time now is the time to look for that
nature positive climate neutral
equitable future okay mark goff great
stuff thanks for talking to us today
well that's all from us for today thanks
for watching